hello hello are you happy
everybody is happy I gotta walk forever
for this oh my god does every worse
going down okay you didn't take me to go
down but to Funkytown problem oh snap oh
no all right where do we go what do we
offer to go down we're going here
oh we can't go there what about us they
are don't take my other hiding place
maybe here's a good idea oh no that's
not good right leg you come with me leg
we have to do something anyone DNA I'm a
leg oh no don't don't don't no don't
don't make noises alright fine fine fine
fine fine fine fine
turn up to Landon Donovan under all
right leg teach me how to run faster
thank you thank you know that I can say
that you know the deccan it then I can
the neck your neck
hey hey
we're gonna do this am i walking
backwards again yes I have god damn I'm
a [ __ ]
can you run in this game
I have a stretch hammer [ __ ] like
these ladders shot through six pitches
yeah yeah
MLG [ __ ] yeah huh nothing I don't see
how anything bad can happen from this
are you [ __ ] kidding me
all right I'm hiding in here
he's coming please don't find me sick of
this [ __ ] I'm sick of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was gonna stop making sad plays funny
stop walking please stop stop whatever
your day ha it's not funny huh oh my god
Bob what is he doing I sexy okay okay
okay Oh sugar tits oh my god
don't turn around a firesteel of amnesia
I just [ __ ] broke it
uh-huh ah come on I have found over
there hey how you doing I'm just gonna
come close and look at you I expect oh
hey George though and sanity potion
that's lovely thank you very much torso
you're welcome really nothing there's
something bad about these oh my god I
know it why didn't you tell me you just
nod no you just all right towards the
dudes are big I don't know Betty I don't
even know it's gonna go first huh okay
go first check if it's safe it's safe
reader I promise
oh go umbrellas
my name I hope you enjoyed the scary
montage if you did why not give it a
like and add it to your favorite it
would really help me out a lot so thank
you bro if you want to see more of these
type of videos that I make then why not
subscribe and join the bro army today
seriously though why aren't you
subscribed yet anyway leave a comment
also telling me which was your favorite
part or comment about whatever you want
[Music]